i
[Música]
españa recibe con alivio por fin más
vacunas contra el cob y de 19 tras días
de escasez lo que provocó que muchas
comunidades autónomas españolas tuvieran
que atrasan e incluso que pagar su plan
de vacunación pues en las neveras
estaban vacías sin dosis para
administrar a partir de hoy lunes pues
se retoma este plan de vacunación con 52
mil dosis de la vacuna moderna que
tendrían que haber llegado inicialmente
en la semana pasada y también con dosis
de la vacuna facer que llega en menor
cantidad de la inicialmente revista pero
según los expertos estos incidentes no
deberían alterar sensiblemente el plan
de vacunación español aunque avisan de
que las futuras dosis recibidas a lo
largo de estos meses serán claves para
respetar el plan de vacunación
[Música]
el programa de vacunación en alemán y
fue presentados del comienzo como un
motivo de esperanza como el programa que
ayudaría a eliminar restricciones y
volver a una normalidad y aunque para
muchos sigue siendo así también es
cierto que se está convirtiendo en un
gran dolor de cabeza para las
autoridades uno de los temas más
controversiales ahora se refiere a la
consecución de las vacunas que se
realizó a nivel europeo y mucho acá se
están preguntando si se realizó con el
enfoque adecuado en particular a la luz
de los recientes problemas entre la
comisión europea y la farmacéutica
astrazéneca y también por otro lado
están los problemas nacionales locales
con la distribución ha habido trabas
organizacionales y burocráticas que han
dificultado el desarrollo de ese
programa en las regiones las autoridades
han defendido su política de vacunación
y han asegurado que se discutirá un plan
nacional que ayude por un lado a
resolver los problemas y por el otro a
cumplir con las metas de vacunación
[Música]
después de varios días de tensiones
entre la compañía anglo sueca
astrazéneca y la unión europea bruselas
ha decidido tomar una polémica medida a
partir de ahora todas las vacunas que se
fabriquen dentro de suelo europeo sólo
se podrán exportar si se tiene en la
autorización expresa de los países de la
unión europea la unión lo ve e insiste
en que quieres sobre todo vigilar las
vacunas que se exportan especialmente
porque sospecha que la compañía
astrazéneca exportó vacunas inicialmente
previstas para la unión europea asia
reino unido después de varios días de
negociaciones entre la farmacéutica y la
comisión europea y a pesar de que los
argumentos no convencieron a bruselas
finalmente la farmacéutica ha dado en
parte su brazo a torcer y ha dicho que
enviará 40 millones de dosis a la unión
europea de aquí a marzo eso es la mitad
de lo previsto porque la farmacéutica
insiste en que tiene problemas en una de
las plantas de fabricación de la vacuna
[Música]